notre invité politique ce matin c'est
donc eric woerth bonjour merci beaucoup
d'être avec nos députés doit ce
président de la commission de
l'assemblée nationale
à démonter les républicains bien
évidemment je le pense
pendant vingt minutes où on intervient
en partenariat avec la presse
quotidienne régionale représenté par
pascal jalabert bon général du groupe
ebra les journaux régionaux de l'est de
la france on commence en parlant de la
crise sanitaire eric woerth et de ces
émeutes en guadeloupe la situation est
toujours très tendue sur place avec des
violences des manifestations contre le
passé vaccinale et l'obligation contre
le pass and i ter et l'obligation
vaccinale des soignants qui ont dégénéré
qui s'étendent le gouvernement à décider
l'envoi d'hommes du raid et du gign il
ya une réunion autour de jean castex
elle cet après midi avec les élus de
l'île est ce qu'un gouvernement adopte
la bonne méthode on était en tout cas il
ya des émeutes qui sont maintenant
extrêmement grave autant qu'on puisse en
juger par les les images et par les
commentaires ces quelques unes c'est une
situation qui échappe et d'ailleurs
probablement aux syndicats eux-mêmes qui
avait déclenché un mouvement de grève
sur / lesure sur le poste sanitaire sur
l'obligation vaccinale pour certaines
catégories de personnel enfin bon pour
des nouvelles de très mauvais sujets qui
atteindra d'ici est en train d'échapper
aux syndicats est maintenant au
gouvernement on va voir on va voir ce
n'est pas la première fois qu'il ya des
émeutes malheureusement l'envoi de
forces de l'ordre et des six heures est
la première des priorités c'est
l'autorité c'est de rétablir l'ordre
comme dans toute démocratie donc il faut
rétablir l'ordre et j'espère que les
gendarmes les policiers vont arriver
supplémentaires vont arriver très vite
et que les clés les habitants vont
pouvoir retrouver une vie une vie
normale à une vie normale aussi pendant
une vague de coheed supplémentaires une
vie normale aussi dans des dans des
territoires aujourd'hui qui connaissent
beaucoup de chômage avec des jeunes
désorientés
ou peu peu occupé qui provoque beaucoup
de sujets mais enfin là il ya des voyous
lassé des séries de voyous iliad et les
atteintes aux biens des atteintes aux
personnes en tir à balle réelle contre
la police donc il faut rétablir
absolument l'ordre de façon très
puissante il ya des protestations dans
d'autres pays d'europe contre les
décisions qui sont prises par les
gouvernements pour lutter contre ces
cinq là on a vu des mobilisations en
autriche aux pays bas en belgique est ce
que vous redoutez que ce mouvement de
colère ne gagne la france écoutez on
voit bien comment réagirez soit même pas
de façon violente mais à une
à une hypothétique annonce de
confinement comme comme celle du canon
sur le gouvernement autrichien ou hulu
le gouvernement hollandais
psychologiquement on peut plus fort je
leur personne n'est prête à ça
l'économie n'est pas prête à ça c'est
moins qu'on puisse dire mais le met mais
même dans sa vie personnelle et puis à
quelques quelques encablures de noël ce
serait totalement
insupportable socialement alors ça crée
évidemment des émeutes comme
malheureusement souvent aujourd'hui le
monde est de plus en plus violents
faut-il sont de plus en plus actif
à ce sujet ah oui c'est pas n'importe
quel sujet on voit bien qu'elle a que
souvent que peu de réponses il reste la
violence et puis et puis y'a pas de
patience on n'attend pas alors c'est
évidemment pas la population dans son
ensemble c'est pas des guerres civiles
s'est passé pas des blogs contre des
blocs mais c'est quand même des gens
organisés grâce aux réseaux sociaux et
qui contestent l'ordre et l'autorité
quel que soit l'endroit de drôles
viennent donc il faut le combattre avec
une grande grande rigueur une grande
grande ville sans que la main tremble
faut-il carrément instaurer une
obligation vaccinale ça simplifierait
les choses y compris pour l'hôpital qui
semble moins prêt à affronter cette vol
que les précédentes coûtaient l'hôpital
elle a beaucoup travaillé depuis depuis
maintenant beaucoup de beaucoup de moi
avec ses vagues successives 5e ça veut
dire qu'il y en a quand même eu quatre
avants dont deux extrêmement puissante
je le personnel enfin chacun connaît des
hôpitaux le personnel est évidemment
fatigué à bout de souvent à bout de
nerfs et pourtant il faut qu'ils fassent
face c'est dans son sens dans sa mission
il le sait d'ailleurs il le fera je n'ai
pas de doute là dessus mais il ya
beaucoup de désorganisation il ya la
désorganisation dehors même du coc vide
par la difficulté de recruter par
exemple par parfois un nombre
d'arrêts-maladie au dessus de la normale
par des services qui n'ont pas de
personnel soignant pas de médecin ou pas
suffisamment d'infirmières c'est très
très complexe aller dans les ehpad aller
dans les hôpitaux dans les centres de
soins il ya un manque cruel de personnel
médical
quand il manque de personnel
aux us et oui oui sont les bonnes en
tout cas pour former un médecin comme on
dit il faut il faut du temps mais ça
fait déjà longtemps qu'on tente de le
faire mais le mode d'exercice de la
médecine a changé probablement les
rémunérations à l'hôpital soit en trop
faible savignac et des si des
différences de rémunération entre les
services non par un médecin qui arrive
comme ça d'urgence pour pour remplacer
quelqu'un irait bien mieux payés que
quelqu'un qui est là tout le temps tout
ça crée beaucoup de conflits entre les
uns et les autres la médecine de ville
également qu'elle premier maillon est
trop faible aujourd'hui beaucoup de
médecins partent en retraite ont bien du
mal à trouver des successeurs pour faire
d'ailleurs autant d'heures souvent que
ce qu'ils faisaient donc il faut sans
doute encore une fois repenser aux
repensais à l'offre de soins et et ça
c'était quelque chose de très longue
longue haleine cependant les la
démographie médicale chez très
différentes d'un territoire à l'autre
manuelle mâcon qui est en tournée dans
votre région des hautes france ces
jours-ci il a fait des annonces pour les
établissements de santé des autres
france mais aussi pour le ferroviaire
pour l'industrie qu'est ce que vous
pensez tous à vous féliciter de ces
annonces qui sont faites pour votre
région et de ses millions sont d'une
manière générale le président la
république fait pas mal d'annoncés en ce
moment alors certains peuvent dire que
c'est électoraliste d'autre que ses
besoins on vous sait pas été moi j'ai un
peu d'expérience voilà j'ai vécu pas mal
de campagne électorale et
présidentielles j'ai jamais vu un
président ne pas faire un peu
d'électoralisme à l'avant une campagne
en chacun chaque président le fait comme
selon sa propre personnalité
par les républicains le président
français n'a pas lieu d'être pour vous
le président a beaucoup dépensé mais il
a beaucoup dépensé pour la crise la
vraie question c'est celle ci quand vous
regardez combien dépense le président de
la république ce président a pas
tellement plus dépensé que les autres au
fond peut-être un peu plus que monsieur
hollande monsieur hollande assez peu de
de choses à dire et à faire donc la
question est les ailes et pas sur le
quoi qu'il en coûte parce qu'une grande
partie de la dépense vient du quoi qu'il
en coûte et puis au delà arrêté au delà
de nom il faut pas la fin il faut pas
l'arrêter ici il faut l'arrêter il
fallait le faire il fallait faire les le
pouvoir d'achat c'est quand même
maintenu ou à peu près quand la france
on avait une récession de 8 à 9% donc
c'est s'éteint c'est a plutôt un bon
résultat les entreprises ont moins fermé
le chômage on était quand même nettement
moins important qu'on ne le pensait
contrat plutôt en voie de régression
donc il ya des bons résultats quand il
ya des bons résultats faut pas hésiter à
le dire sinon on n'est pas on n'est pas
crédible maintenant il faut arrêter un
moment donné de dépenser sans compter
sur le quoi qu'il en coûte c'est qu'on
compte pas et ce qui compte c est en
fait l'objectif qu'on veut atteindre
l'objectif qu'on veut atteindre
aujourd'hui c'est quand même aussi un
retour je prends comme on peut le dire
si ce sans doute pas à l'équilibré des
finances publiques mais une situation
saine de nos finances publiques et il
faut plus qu'on ait recours à la dette
de là avec la même façon qu'on a eu
recours à la dette ces derniers ces
derniers temps et ça ça veut dire il
faut faire une très grosse différence
entre les dépenses courantes de tous les
jours qu'il faut rendre de plus en plus
efficace et ça c'est un vrai sujet
français la dépense française elle n'est
pas assez efficace la dépense
d'enseignement n'est pas assez efficace
beaucoup de dépenses ne le sont pas par
rapport à d'autres pays donc on doit la
rendre plus efficace et plus compliqué
que de l'augmenter par la nette puis le
deuxième point c'est de faire une
différence entre ce qui relève de
l'investissement c'est à dire qu'on a
investi pour augmenter la croissance
potentielle du pays pour voilà comme
comme une entreprise investit et puis la
dépense qui n'est pas une dépense
d'investissement mais c'est une voix un
peu dissonante
porter chez les républicains qui ont
plutôt tendance à critiquer le président
de la république dans les milliards
qu'ils dépensent à la proche de la
campagne dans sa gestion de la crise en
disant qu'il a trop dépensé que la
troupe augmenter la dette augmenter
dépenses publiques ça veut dire qu'ils
ne sont pas crédibles
je raisonne pas en je raisonne pas en
troupeau aussi
je dis ce que je pense et ce que je
pense et ce que j'ai voté mais ce que
les républicains ont voté aussi c'est à
dire des des projets de loi de finances
rectificative que le sénat a voté
également sur l'économie parce qu' il
fallait le faire il fallait ce jeu c'est
pas une crise économique qu'on a vécu
une crise sanitaire qui sont
retransformés pas vraiment d'ailleurs en
crise économique s'est transformé en
fermeture en confinement l'économie il
fallait bien de continuer à injecter les
choses si si votre coeur arrête de bâton
continue à essayer d'organiser la
circulation semble sanguine en essayant
de relancer le locker et puis à un
moment donné ça marche malheureusement
ça ne marche pas en l'occurrence la
crise économique a été bien combattu la
crise sanitaire dans les derniers
moments et beaucoup me 2,2 les premiers
moments ont été difficiles d'abord de
comprendre de quoi il s'agit c'est ça a
été le cas en france cette file cas
aussi dans d'autres pays donc je ne sais
pas c'est pas là dessus qu'on doit qu on
doit attaquer d'ailleurs le débat des
républicains les débats qui ont lieu
actuellement pour très très peu sur le
diagnostic concernant la crise sanitaire
alors on va y revenir sa porte notamment
sur la question des impôts il en a été
question hier mais d'abord puisque vous
parlez du projet de loi de finances
rectificative parmi les mesures il ya
l'indemnité inflation là dans ce projet
devrait sinon significative celle
indemnité de 100 euros aka promise jean
castex à tous les français gagnant moins
de 2000 euros net par mois ça a été
retoquée par le sénat qui dit que
l'assiette est trop large et qui dit que
ça va coûter trop cher et dont ils
raison les sénateurs les sénateurs ont
toujours raison par principe il honte
ils ont voté donc ils ont des règles des
raisons en tout cas pour cela
l'assemblée l'a voté
nous même l'avons voté
défense ça se discute c'est vrai que 60
euros c'est beaucoup beaucoup d'argent
pour pour pas mal de gens c'est pas
beaucoup d'argent pour pour d'autres et
que bon at on besoin est ce que ça a
mené ce que ça ça efface une partie de
l'inflation c'est surtout les coûts
énergétiques qui était qui était visé
sans le son le dire je n'en suis pas sûr
une meilleure nouvelle que la baisse de
la fiscalité parce que la baisse de la
fiscalité sur le sur le sur le sur
l'énergie il ya beaucoup de fiscalité
sur l'énergie la baisse de la fiscalité
à ce moment là il faut que les la
fiscalité qui a baissé la moindre hausse
du produit à neil l'impact de la baisse
de la fiscalité et puis résultat vous
retrouver avec des recettes fiscales en
moins et vous avez bien du mal à les
remonter après alors que je n'ai pas
noté que l'état français où la dépense
publique française elle était sûre
financer vous l'avez remarqué elle est
quand même plutôt sous financé aussi
fiscalité c'est une
aucune réponse n'avoir aucune réponse
expliqué limiter l'augmentation des prix
de l'énergie comme c'est fait et n'avoir
aucune réponse en termes de prestations
supplémentaires le gouvernement l'a fait
c'est une région de ponctuelle non j'ai
dit que les sénateurs avaient deux dans
l'ordre
de la rigueur ils ont raison on n'avait
pas besoin d'un et militer d'inflation à
plus de 3 milliards d'euros jeudi par
rapport à la fiscalité c'est une
meilleure réponse que la fiscalité
aucune baisse de 1,21 mécanisme avec ces
prix de l'énergie que celui précité les
carburants qui fut tué mais là il ya
quelque chose quand même qu'il faut dire
à un moment donné on doit lire dans les
débats des républicains mais on parle
pas d'économie
sociale ni politique sociale ni de
politique économique c'est quand même
bizarre de relais nos candidats ne sont
pas responsables mais à un moment donné
il je pense qu'il faut quand même
s'afficher à dire que les questions vont
bien mais je si c'est pas les questions
qui intéressent voilà peut pas passer
12h30 sur la sécurité et l'immigration
et puis après une demi-heure sur
l'économie à chaque fois à la fin ça
c'est pas possible
la transition écologique elle a dédié le
changement de production d'énergie etc
tout ça on est tous maintenant d'accord
ça va coûter cher et que le prix de
l'énergie va quand même plutôt augmenter
on est devant un mur d'investissements
en terme de
deux nouvelles énergies comme en termes
de de construction par exemple de
centrales nucléaires ou d'entretien des
de nos propres centrales donc donc il
faut il faudra pouvoir l'affronter et il
faut voir accompagner sa d'une
transition sociale c'est-à-dire dort
mieux réfléchir à comment on accompagne
les gens qui seront nécessairement un
peu à la traîne ou laissé au bord du
chemin d'une augmentation des prix de
2,2 de l'énergie quand on veut changer
de société et chacun le dit il n'y a pas
le journal il n'y a pas trois tribunes
chaque jour pour dire qu'on va changer
de deux mondes sans doute mais en
revanche pour changer de monde on va
devoir beaucoup beaucoup investir mettre
beaucoup beaucoup d'argent des milliers
de milliards d'euros un peu partout dans
le monde ça va se traduire un moment
donné par une augmentation des prix donc
l'état ne peut pas à chaque fois qu'on
pense et parce que lui-même n'a pas
l'argent nécessaire pour le faire il
faut bien regarder les populations qui
sont de plus en plus impactées et avoir
des des des réponses durables et pas
uniquement des réponses conjoncturelles
mot sur ces questions budget sénat
examine en ce moment le budget et les
sénateurs les républicains ne veulent
pas aller jusqu'au bout de l'examen du
budget ils veulent ne pas voter la
première partie ce qui ferait tomber la
suite du budget vous allez bien les
sénateurs ont toujours raison mais quand
même est-ce que c'est pas un
affaiblissement du parlement de ne pas
aller jusqu'au bout le sénat utilise
tous les moyens qui sont qui sont les
siens il aurait pu aussi ne pas regarder
du tout la première partie en rejetant
le texte d'ailleurs le renvoyant
à l'assemblée nationale immédiatement
prises ont décidé de rejouer moi je n'ai
pas à juger du du de la stratégie
d'études d'un texte c'est un texte
d'avant élection voilà tout tout ce qui
peut exiger le même c'est un examen
budgétaire rapide par le par le sénat
mais on est dans une phase électorale
chacun fait de la politique aussi
bah oui je sais des organes politiques
l'assemblée et le sénat sont bas au
meilleur sens du terme d des
institutions politiques donc ça veut
dire que l'assemblée nationale aura le
texte un peu plus tôt différemment le
sénat va gagner du temps donc il pourra
creuser d'autres d'autres fois on se
voit avec nos amis sénateurs tout à
l'heure en commission mixte paritaire
pour le projet de loi de finances
rectificative on va parler de l'impôt
puisqu'il en a été question dans le
débat des républicains armés d'abord
marine le pen qui veulent exonérés
d'impôt sur le revenu et d'impôt sur les
sociétés tous les jeunes de moins de 30
ans c'est une bonne mesure pour la
jeunesse phonique tu chaussée rien enfin
j'ose le concours le concours de de
celui qui dépensera le plus qui croire à
la prestation supplémentaire qui a
exonéré d'impôt une voie là on en est
déjà en est déjà à l'impôt perclus de
deux niches fiscales des exonérations en
tous genres enfin c'est pas dit solution
la solution c'est comment non pas en
relance parce que l'économie française
entre nouvelle est plutôt relancer donc
comment on consolide l'économie
française comment réindustraliser la
france c'est des sujets anciens ce n'est
pas tout à fait nouveau mais on est
quand même plutôt en train de le faire
aujourd'hui avant d'en parler mais on
n'est pas là on est plutôt en train de
le faire il faut c'est si ça les vrais
sujets on en attend pas candidat pour
savoir s'il va exonérer d'impôt et ci ou
ça de toute façon pour payer les
services publics passe quand même dans
le même temps le même candidat demande
une augmentation des services publics et
comme les services publics y sont pas
financés ça s'appelle ça s'appelle le
déficit et que derrière il était
financée par de la dette qui à un moment
donné donnera son coût augmenter un jour
ou l'autre bon c'est pas c'est tout ça
ne semble pas très responsable moi
j'attends pas les candidats sur sur
comment ils vont faire pour verser
encore plus d'argent public ou augmenter
encore plus le nombre de fonctionnaires
pour tous c'était c'était l'idée d'un
sénateur célèbre qui sape qui s'appelait
malheureusement paix à son âme serge
dassault oui c'est sa relation à militer
pour la flat tax comme on dit à 15%
pendant des années des années c'est
irréaliste c'est assez irréaliste parce
que ça fait bien comme ça c'était plus
simple mais c'est pas du tout un sujet
d'abord parce que ça veut dire qu'il ya
déjà 50 ou 60 % de gens qui payent pas
l'impôt sur le revenu donc vous avez à
faire payer 15% moi je comprends que
c'est pour tout le monde alors si vous
commencez à dire ah bah non sauf les
plus précaires ça veut dire qu'il ya
déjà à taux zéro donc et de taux et à
taux zéro puis un taux à 15 puis à un
moment donné on va se dire et messieurs
quand même qui gagnent plus de x cela
quand même en toi un peu alors on va
mettre un autre taupe et un jour créé
l'impôt sur le revenu enfin il ya un
moment donné vous savez la simplicité
c'est pas nécessairement toujours la
même la bonne solution et dans le
domaine de l'imposition votre choix
simple pour les gens mais le 6 lits
systèmes fiscaux c'est vrai pour plein
d'autres et à son complexe pense qu'il
essaie de coller des réalités le débat
des républicains que largement
personne je n'ai pas pris position
je veux très bien sûr mais je ne suis
pas encore pour qui
il y en a déjà eu 3 donc je me dépêche
un catholique
c'est des conversations c'est six mois
des débats que des conversations
d'ailleurs de plutôt de bon niveau et je
pense que les candidats sont bien entrés
dans leur propre sujet je trouve que
personne n'émerge vraiment mais je
trouve quand même que donc ils sont tous
bons mais je trouve quand même que
qu'on ressasse les les mêmes idées qu'en
2007 où qu'en 2000 ou quand même qu'en
2012 quoi on est on a toujours
on est toujours sur les mêmes sujets non
ça veut dire aussi
je ne sais pas non y'a pas vrai
un peu des deux il ya toujours plus de
violence il ya toujours les banlieues on
nous parle des ans nous on nous parle
des cités comme si c'était une grande
découverte soit je ne sais pas si vous
savez enfin dans les années 2005 les
elle était en feu c'était là que c'était
la guérilla et hier le débat sur l'armée
ou par mail à évident que vaut pas
envoyer l'armée laisse quand même une
drôle d'idée mais guéri
c'était la guérilla bonjour j'ai rien
contre ricky il y défend ses valeurs
mais à l'époque il va un vrai villepin
voulait envoyer l'armée et sarkozy qui
était ministre de l'intérieur ne le
voulait pas finalement chirac a arbitré
mais l'armée était prête à aller pour
faire quoi pour faire la guerre en
france allez l'armee n'est pas fait pour
soi puis l'armée n'a pas les effectifs
pour ça leur miel doit garder des
effectifs les former à voir ses
effectifs dans les opérations
extérieures
bon c'est comme l'idée de rétablissement
d'un service militaire c'est une idée
qui était émise il a par michel barnier
ça nécessite beaucoup beaucoup de
discussions c'est un changement on bosse
ici on veut uniquement que l'armée et
des jeunes pour qui un brassage social
peut-être pas tout à fait le rôle de
l'armée je crois hélas pour nous
défendre lé là pour défendre les armes
françaises la république française les
valeurs françaises et puis si possible
aussi elle est là pour coopérer avec les
armées européennes au sein de l'otan
certes mais également d'être peut-être
dans les perspectives à venir dans une
vision plus armée de l'ensemble de
l'europe sinon on n'y a pas de puissance
hier dans le parisien aujourd'hui en
france herald harman a parlé je le cite
de l'obsession immigrationnisme
républicain qui singe zemmour ou le pen
en parlant le grand remplacement nommé
le grand remplacement c'est
essentiellement remplacement de zemmour
par le pen ou le pen par zemmour ça ce
sera un grand remplacement n'y a pas de
grand remplacement l'une à tout le monde
peut venir sur des plateaux de télé né
des chiffres faux enfin il ya un bon il
ya évidemment un niveau d'immigration
qui est plus élevé qu'il ya dix ans mais
pas énormément plu plus élevé la
question c'est celle intégration ou
l'assimilation comme vous voulez qu'on
emploie ce terme et qu'on nous donne du
contenu juridique ou du contenu
politique il faut que nous ayons une
immigration à l'intérieur de la france
est absolument nécessaire donc il ya pas
de moratoire possible mais il ya en tout
cas
une volonté absolue qui est celle de
contrôler l'immigration qui était la
nôtre à partir de là toutes les
politiques publiques doivent en découler
comme les politiques européennes peut
pas y avoir des politiques migratoires
différente à ce qu'ont fait les
allemands à un moment donné il ya
quelques ya quelques mois était une
erreur profonde
gérald monte darmana monte un peu le ton
il était lui-même république n ya pas si
longtemps il est ministre de l'intérieur
elle il faut qu'ils rétablissent l'ordre
voilà déjà dans sa propre pensée tout
quand il dit que le candidat qui inspire
le plus
aimé emmanuel macron il est ni de droite
ni de gauche donc à un moment donné
certains peuvent s'y retrouver on n'est
plus dans un débat bloc à bloc il y
avait les socialistes il y avait la
droite bon on ne s'y retrouvaient pas et
puis on partageait un certain nombre
d'idées à un moment donné
on est d'abord français t on est d'abord
on est d'abord français ça ça surplombe
l'ensemble des divisions scion comprend
pas ça ça peut
devenir le tube ce qui nous reste peu de
temps mais que j'aime bien mais on avait
gilles platret à votre place vendredi
qui nous disait qu eric zemmour a libéré
la parole chez les républicains vont
partager cet âge non non pas du tout ne
pas besoin d'un libérateur de la parole
avant on avait des libérateurs du
territoire on avait des gens ces
voiliers voyez le niveau quand même
malheureusement on est en train de se
fracasser monsieur zemmour n'a pas
attendu enfin si un parti comme les
républicains a besoin d'attendre
monsieur zemmour pour se révéler mon
dieu ça veut dire que ça n'existe plus
donc je prends là je pense quand même
que les débats aujourd'hui tourne trop
autour de du régalien aussant cqt
sécuritaire et migratoire c'est pas
parce que je pense que des mauves et mcd
thème réel et il faut évidemment les
continuelles et travailler il faut
évidemment considérer que c'est une
priorité on peut pas laisser s'implanter
la question ce n'est pas tellement la
migration la question c'est aujourd'hui
le trafic de drogue la question dans les
banlieues ce qui pourrit les banlieues
aussi ce qui pourrait les banlieues
c'est le trafic de drogue c'est les
points de lille c'est tous ces sujets ce
qui pourrit d'ailleurs une partie du
monde et pas uniquement la france donc
ce qu'il faut tenter de régler mais
c'est aussi un problème mondial je suis
allé en colombie je suis allé je suis
allé dans un dans ces pays là on voit
bien que c'est des économies on voit
bien que les afghans dans cette
république terrible face à puce et pour
une république d'ailleurs enfin dans ce
pays terrible et des gens dans ce pays
qui va se mettre au ban des nations je
l'espère on est en train de réhabiliter
le travil enfin la culture du pavot
parce qu'évidemment plus rien ne
fonctionne donc c'est une réponse
globale mais la france l'a ses propres
réponses il faut casser les points de
deal il faut casser les dealers il faut
créer des centres de rééducation
tout ça doit être au fait et de façon
extrêmement puissante et je suis
d'accord pour dire et je l'avais écrit
il ya quelques temps partir du moment où
il ya eu un couac il en coûte économique
il faut quand même abandonné savoir
mettre plus de moyens dans le
rétablissement de l'ordre dans notre
pays
[Musique]